welcome back to Facebook with
uncensitive Vladimir Putin is probably
one of the most hated leaders in the
world right now that's what happens when
you invade illegally a Sovereign Nation
and audio Army distorted innocent people
but as well as opposing the West
Financial military backing for Ukraine a
substantial movement of digital
influences hold put in a bizarrely high
regard praising him as a peace-loving
leader who stands up his country Jackson
Hinkle a conservative commentator in
YouTube over 260 000 subscribers is a
prominent voice in this pro-putin
community recently tweeted Putin has got
on his side in his quest to defeat NATO
satanists so why is he saying all this
well let's ask him join me now is the
Putin fan YouTuber Jackson the Russian
British host of the trigonometry podcast
Constantine kissing okay welcome to both
of you Jackson I don't get it uh
Vladimir Putin invaded illegally a
democratic sovereign country has rigged
total Mayhem is killed innocent women
children's bomb maternity hospitals uh
he's been on a barbaric Rampage why
would you choose this moment to Revere
him
I would choose this moment because most
of what is said about Vladimir Putin in
the mainstream press by Talking Heads
like yourself is just factually not true
just like everything that people like
you said about covet uh the fact of the
matter is this war that everyone talks
about that so so-called started on
February 24 2022 actually began in 2014
after the U.S led a violent coup on the
Ukrainian government that was
democratically elected when people
specifically ethnic Russians in the
dombas decided that they didn't want a
U.S installed puppy government filled
with Nazis they vocalized their opinions
and for that they were met with violence
and aggression by the Ukrainian
government who slaughtered them for
eight years fifteen thousand people died
in this fighting while Putin tried to
achieve peace through the Minsk Accords
and the mints two Accords all of which
ended up being rejected by the Ukrainian
government at the behest of Germany in
the United States
Ukrainian government continue to push
forward despite the fact that Putin
wanted peace and they said that they
wanted to join NATO they said they
wanted to have nukes right on Russia's
border and because of that Putin stepped
in and said hey look we're going to stop
the Bloodshed we're going to stop the
NATO escalation we're going to stop the
risk of potentially this unfolding into
a full-fledged nuclear war and we're
going to do what needs to be done we're
going to liberate the ethnic Russians in
Ukraine we're going to denatify you
again and we're going to denotify all
right I'm giving you a good chance to
answer that I've got to say a lot of
that I thought was a Crocker crap but
let me go to Constantine kiss it because
it said I find this attitude completely
mind-blowing there used to be a time
when Americans in particular certainly
conservative Americans when faced with a
choice between a democratic sovereign
country and a murderous Russian dictator
invading them they wouldn't even
hesitate to support the ukrainians in
this battle what has happened this term
people like this guy into Putin lovers
who just think he's a man of Peace well
he did say that Putin stepped into and
the Bloodshed which I thought is
interesting given what's been going in
Ukraine for the last year and a half but
actually there's a history I mean first
of all isolationism is a policy that has
had some support in America historically
in fact 1939 1940 there were people
marching up and down Times Square saying
Hitler hasn't done anything to us let's
have peace with Hitler so Jackson's
following in their footsteps there but
you were right in your introduction this
is a very online phenomenon and I was
just in several conservative states in
America West Virginia uh Utah you go
around as Ukraine flags on on most of
the houses there so this is quite a
fringe position but I think uh Jackson
actually alluded to some of the reasons
there is a growing movement of people
who feel that they've been liked to by
the mainstream media quite rightly by
the way particularly over things like
covet yeah and they've developed a sort
of teenage oppositional Defiance
disorder where they now think that the
truth is whatever is the opposite of
what the mainstream is saying and we've
just heard a very good representation of
that yeah I mean Jackson again
you've lost our connection with you
unfortunately which will immediately
lead people on social media to claim
it's a conspiracy and we've silenced him
that's not the case we actually look as
you saw his head froze in mid-rent uh we
could hear his voice no he can't hear
either I think so constantly let's just
keep talking until we get Jackson back I
don't know I mean I don't know where
this mindset takes them I always say to
to conservatives uh who come up with
this kind of stuff well what did you
feel about the invasion of Kuwait by
Saddam Hussein the first one because
they weren't part of NATO QA and yet the
Americans along with the British raced
to throw Saddam Hussein out of there I
get told well he didn't have nuclear
weapons what we thought he did actually
have weapons of mass destruction
um that whole period but it didn't stop
us doing what was morally the right
thing to do and it's that weird moral
maze that they've all got themselves
into where they're now defending the
very person that historically
conservatives would have railed against
and a KGB Colonel of course you remember
that too and it's interesting because
one of the arguments people like Jackson
make it's a Pity we've lost them because
I'd love to have more of a debate but
one of the things they seem to think is
that this guy is a representation of the
Christian tradition which is interesting
because uh this is a man who's had
several children out of wedlock with his
mistress and by the way what's
interesting is the people like Jackson
often talk about how under Vladimir
Putin Russia has become this great
country and by the way Putin has
stabilized Russia there's no argument
about that but most of the Elites in
Russia have their children and their
wives in Europe This is interesting
isn't it because they claim that Russia
is this great place on the Vladimir
Putin yet all of those people place
their families outside which is uh tells
you a lot about what they actually think
about the country so uh we've got
Jackson back I think Jackson uh
genuinely the connection went down so
there's no conspiracy we weren't trying
to silence you you no I just find it odd
I mean for argument's sake when
I've been saying invaded Kuwait did you
feel that he was a peace loving guy that
we should be instinctively supporting or
did you agree with American
conservatives then that what should
actually happen is Desert Storm and
General Schwarzkopf should be leading
the American charge to repel him and if
you felt the latter why would you feel
differently about someone like Putin
doing this in Ukraine
well I don't know if you know Pierce I'm
only 23 years old so I didn't have fully
fledged opinions on that at the time but
what I think is very interesting is for
all the Western officials that are so
outraged over what Putin is doing in
Ukraine why were they not outrage over
what NATO did to Yugoslavia or what NATO
did to Libya or what the United States
did in Iraq and Afghanistan or Syria the
United States drone operation program in
Africa had a 95 civilian death rate for
everyone to be so up in arms over Putin
liberating these ethnic Russians in
Ukraine from Nazis it is just I have no
answer Jackson Jackson the trouble is
some of the stuff you said in your
initial response is historically
defensible you can argue from 2014
there's been this issue there I get that
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
say but when you say that Putin's only
game here is to go and Liberate the
ukrainians from Nazis you just sound
completely Bonkers Bonkers not say there
aren't some far-right people with Nazi
tendencies in Ukraine there are as there
are in many countries but the idea this
is a nazi-run country when the president
is Jewish never mind anything else is
laughably ridiculous
well just because each Jewish doesn't
mean he's not seeking his azov Nazi
thugs on ethnic Russians in the Dom back
you think a Jewish president is going to
be actively promoting Nazism
the ones with swastika tattoos and
Hitler tattoos and Mario for example
here's one question one question what
I'll say is if you're so outraged over
the you know the the atrocities
allegedly of Putin in Ukraine and all
these ukrainians that have been killed
and you tweet about it non-stop why did
you not tweet once about the atrocities
that were perpetrated by the Ukrainian
government from 2014 to 2022 against
those ethnic Russians in the Dom bass
well yeah well I my family are actually
largely ethnic Russians in Ukraine uh
the idea that there's a significant body
of people in Ukraine who by virtue of
being ethnic Russians support what
Vladimir Putin is doing it's complete uh
hogwash frankly
um and the lots of other points that
have been met I mean you're right there
are some far-right elements in Ukraine
as there are in America there's of
Battalion the Jackson's referring to was
formed after Russia invaded in 2014. in
the same way that if Mexico invaded the
United States it'd probably be some
far-right people going out and fighting
there so uh he's got the the whole thing
backwards uh which is not surprising you
know what we could probably explore this
in more detail I mean will Jackson I've
got no desire to censor you to stop you
having your views you're entitled to
them I will challenge them uh We've run
out of time tonight but I think we
should do this again another time uh you
can have a platform here we can talk
about these things because a lot of
people seem to agree with you which I
find baffling but that's the reality so
thank you for joining Piers Morgan on
census tonight Constantine always good
to see you